Alle zwei Wochen packt Silvia
Werner ihr Lichtzelt aus
- fürs Fotoshooting ihrer Taschen, die
sie aus recycelten Materialien näht.
Die Bilder stellt sie dann ins Netz.
Die Kunden fragen das auch ab:
‚Ach, haben Sie einen Internetauftritt,
haben Sie auch einen eigenen Shop?‘
Den eigenen Shop haben wir
eigentlich nur gemacht damals,
weil die Kunden danach gefragt haben.
Die Modedesignerin aber möchte
mehr als anonym im Netz verkaufen.
Sie ist Mitglied bei
„Online City Wuppertal“,
einer Plattform nur für Wuppertaler Händler.
Auch Haushaltswarenhändler
Feuerstein ist dabei.
Er muss kämpfen, um Kunden
nicht an die Online-Riesen zu verlieren.
Ein eigener Onlineshop
ist ihm zu teuer,
aber 60 Euro monatlich für den
Wuppertaler Marktplatz findet er gut.
Ich glaube einfach, dass
dieser Ansatz einer lokalen Plattform,
aus der vielleicht mal eine gesamtstädtische
Community entstehen könnte,
genau der richtige ist, um gerade
dem, dem inhabergeführten,
ortsansässigen Einzelhandel
eine Ebene zu geben,
auf der er erfolgreich auch sich
innerhalb der Stadt darstellen kann.
In der eigenen Stadt einkaufen,
ohne bei Regen vor die Tür zu müssen:
Inzwischen bieten rund
60 Wuppertaler Händler
ihre Waren auf dem
Internet-Marktplatz an
und versuchen, dem gesichtslosen
Online-Handel Paroli zu bieten.
Es geht darum, das zu schaffen, was
der reine Onlinehändler eben nicht kann,
sprich: ‘ne Verbindung zu schaffen
zwischen dem stationären Handel,
wo immer noch Beratung,
wo immer noch Service,
wo ein persönliches Gespräch stattfindet.
Geliefert wird noch am selben Tag:
Gegen ein paar Euro nach Hause
- oder aber die Kunden holen die Ware
im Showroom der „Online City“ ab.
Hier können die beteiligten
Händler auch noch
ein Ladenregal als Ausstellungsfläche
mieten, so wie Feuerstein.
Insgesamt sind die Umsätze über
den Marktplatz noch sehr bescheiden,
aber die Wuppertaler Einzelhändler
wollen weitermachen
und gegen das Ladensterben
ihrer Stadt kämpfen.
Auch wenn Silvia Werner ihre
Taschen nach wie vor
vor allem auf Märkten
und im Laden verkauft.
Ich denke, dass das die
einzige Möglichkeit ist,
unsere Innenstädte auch wieder
lebendiger zu gestalten.
Denn so ein … Ich sehe
das wie ein Branchenbuch,
früher hatte man ‘n Buch in
der Hand und guckte so:
Ich brauch‘ ‘nen Klempner, ich
brauch‘ das, ich brauch‘ das.
Heute ist es so, dass wir das
online anbieten können.
Auch wenn die Händler Geduld
und langen Atem brauchen
- Wuppertal hat ein Zeichen gesetzt.
Eine Handvoll anderer Städte in
Deutschland sind bereits nachgezogen
und bauen sich ebenfalls
Einkaufsstraßen im World Wide Web.